[Música]
vamos a hablar de los temas de la salud
con más Romero sala Mario un buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela y comienzo
con una gran agradecimiento por reforzar
esta conmemoración del día internacional
de los refugiados esta vez desde la
perspectiva que a usted le corresponde
la salud Sí por supuesto toca hablar
esto desde muchos ángulos porque esta
condición afecta las vidas cuando dicen
de refugiados de desplazados también
desde muchas perspectivas y es imposible
hacer una lista en el caso de la salud
por ejemplo primero porque los retos son
infinitos prácticamente pero el segundo
también porque son muy distintas las
situaciones según qué lugares
geográficos donde sean estas personas
refugiadas no es difícil generalizar sin
embargo aquí pues para conmemorar el día
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
recordaba algunos de estos retos no
recordaba estas circunstancias sociales
los retos del viaje de un refugiado de
un desplazado la discriminación durante
el viaje o en el momento de llegar al
lugar de destino el aislamiento y
también por supuesto el acceso
inadecuado a los servicios de salud como
de los factores que influyen al final en
el bienestar y en la salud de estas
personas refugiadas o desplazadas por
supuesto También tenemos que tener en
cuenta las malas condiciones muchas
veces que existen de habitabilidad en la
vivienda del trabajo Las barreras de
lenguaje Las barreras culturales no
todas estas cosas que hacen tan difícil
que una persona pueda ejercer ese
derecho a la salud que es universal de
todo el mundo también para los
refugiados y para los desplazados En ese
sentido sin embargo también Es verdad
que la OMS destacó algunas de las cosas
buenas que han sucedido Durante este año
año y medio en ese sentido Por ejemplo
el hecho de que en Apolonia los
refugiados ucranianos tienen un acceso a
la salud universal una cobertura
gratuita para poder acceder a los
servicios sanitarios o que por ejemplo
para ir a otro lugar del mundo no en
Pakistán lograron subir la tasa de
vacunación del covid entre los
refugiados del 5% al 48%, gracias a unas
alianzas con las autoridades locales
entonces bueno es importante recordar
estas cosas que son positivas y también
que muchas veces estas personas
refugiadas tienen mucho que aportar a
los países donde van y que precisamente
cuidar la salud de estas personas hace
que puedan ser precisamente tengan esas
capacidades para participar en la
sociedad que muchas veces es difícil no
en salud se habla mucho de un bucle de
la enfermedad y de la pobreza no ser
pobre te hace estar más enfermo estar
enfermo hace que sea más difícil salir
de situaciones de vulnerabilidad
económica entonces bueno tratar de dar
esos esos digamos esas escaleras para
que los refugiados puedan salir también
de estas situaciones como una de los
prioridades que deberían tener todos los
gobiernos en el mundo claro y esa
situación de círculo vicioso ya es grave
sin ser un refugiado por supuesto Exacto
esa solo una cosa que se suma más bueno
para su siguiente tema madre Esto me
hace recordar mucho Cuando leo
publicaciones sobre migraciones y Cómo
sobreviven las personas en los campos de
refugiados básicamente sobre sus propias
heces Sí al final estos lugares
suelen ser un caldo de digamos para
muchísimas enfermedades además de unas
vidas indignas digamos para esas
personas no vamos a traer un estudio que
ya tiene unos años se publicó en 2019 y
lo que hacía era revisar Cuántos brotes
de enfermedades habían habido en campos
de refugiados entre 2009 y 2017
contabilizaron 364 brotes en 108 Campos
pero aquí lo que a mí me parece más
interesante es que el 75% de esos brotes
fueron de sarampión fueron de cólera y
fueron de meningitis que son
enfermedades que suelen ser prevenibles
simplemente con buenas condiciones de
saneamiento o con las coberturas
vacunales regulares de que todos los
niños deberían tener no cuando cuando
nacen y durante sus primeros años de
vida yo quería hacer hincapié
especialmente en el cólera que es un
tema que hemos hablado ya más de una vez
aquí y por eso también recordamos que
este estudio tiene unos años porque es
que en los últimos dos años
aproximadamente hay un brote sin
precedentes de cólera en todo el mundo y
está precisamente vinculado a los
desplazamientos for a las crisis
climáticas al hacinamiento de personas
refugiadas es una enfermedad muy
fácilmente prevenible con acceso
simplemente agua potable a buenas
medidas de saneamiento y por ejemplo
hubo un brote en asiria en los conventos
de refugiados de Siria es una enfermedad
recurrente en los campos de refugiados
de los rojillas en bangladesh es decir
que precisamente como decíamos es el
gran ejemplo no de que estas poblaciones
están en una situación mucho más
vulnerable de una enfermedad que en
otros lugares con más capacidades es que
ya ni nos acordamos de que existe
prácticamente pero es que es imposible
hablar de algo que uno pensaría que es
tan básico como una alcantarillado en
estas condiciones por supuesto Bueno
vamos a hacer un cambio de tema por otro
que también es bien preocupante India
está empezando a atravesar una ola de
calor que medios locales denuncian ya
podría haber causado decenas y decenas
de muertes Sí claro ese ese podrías
importante porque la información es un
poco confusa los reportes llegan sobre
todo de dos estados de
al norte de la India y en el reporte por
ejemplo en este caso de la agencia
asociated press hablan de 119 muertes en
notar pradesh y 47 en viajar Aunque
estas cifras varían un poco según qué
fuente de información se usa como bien
decías son denuncias por ahora porque
las autoridades sanitarias dicen que no
están Claro que sean muertes provocadas
por estas altas temperaturas que han
abierto una investigación y además es
especialmente polémico porque el oficial
de salud que la semana pasada atribuyó
estas muertes precisamente al calor ha
sido destituido Entonces pues por eso
están surgiendo tantas críticas y tantas
polémicas lo que sí sabemos es Que las
temperaturas han oscilado entre los 42 y
hasta 47-48 grados Celsius temperaturas
muy altas y hay reportes como decíamos
de las agencias y de medios locales que
hablan ya de hospitales totalmente
saturados incluso también de la morgue
de trabajadores sanitarios pues estando
atendiendo a pacientes sin descanso
precisamente por eso escuchamos dos
reportes de familiares de pacientes que
hablan de la situación
no hay ventiladores para mi familiar he
cubierto la ventana con un trozo de tela
para protegerlo de los rayos del sol
directos No hay forma de proteger a un
enfermo del calor ni siquiera dentro del
hospital visité el hospital ayer por la
noche para ingresar a un familiar que
había sufrido un golpe de calor no había
camas disponibles Así que tuve que
volver acá
pues Mara hay mucho que aclarar todavía
sobre este tema pero fíjese la
importancia de que haya una denuncia
periodística precisamente para que se
revise con más cuidado el asunto por
supuesto es muy importante al final que
los ojos no nos olvidemos de que la
salud es de las mismas vidas de las
personas que los ojos periodísticos
estén ahí más allá de este episodio en
particular además las horas de calor son
más frecuentes en India las olas de
calor las altas temperaturas son cada
vez más frecuentes Y por supuesto
también sus consecuencias no hay un
estudio que se publicó en The lanced que
básicamente dice que el aumento de las
muertes por olas de calor en la última
digamos veintena de años ha sido de un
55%
el año 2021 hasta el 2000 desde el año
Perdón 2000 hasta el 2021 y además de
las muertes que es una de las cosas no o
más evidentes en estas oleadas de calor
también hay otras consecuencias como la
pérdida de horas de trabajo con las
consecuentes impactos de esto en la en
la Pues en la en el dinamismo de la
economía y también recordemos que una
hora de calor extrema empeora la
polución del aire que es algo que en
India particularmente ya se cobra miles
y miles de muertes cada año es un
problema además que también agrava
condiciones cardiovasculares es decir
enfermedades del corazón respiratorias
que es especialmente problemático para
adultos mayores para niños que da una
mala calidad del sueño por lo que
también suele tener más afectaciones en
enfermedades o problemas de Salud Mental
y que además es especialmente grave para
personas que no tienen los recursos
económicos para combatir el calor así
sea una simple ventilador o que tienen
que tener trabajos afuera que exijan una
un esfuerzo físico que es especialmente
peligroso precisamente en estos
episodios y además es que estamos
hablando de India pero será cada vez más
frecuente en todo el mundo las muertes
por calor han aumentado un 60% en todo
el mundo en los últimos 20 años Así que
es una es un riesgo al que nos
tendríamos que estar adaptando desde ya
y un llamado de atención gracias a usted
Muchas gracias Ángela